to mention language
use language so no chomsky believes that
language may be at the core of cognition
at the core of everything in the human
mind
what is the connection between language
and vision to you
like what's more fundamental are they
neighbors
is one the parent and the child the
chicken and the egg
oh it's very clear it is vision which is
the parent the fundament the prevention
the fundamental ability
okay so
it comes before you think vision is more
fundamental than language correct
and and and it and yeah you can think of
it either in phylogeny or in ontogeny
so phylogeny means if you look at
evolutionary time
right so you we have vision that
developed 500 million years ago
okay then something like when we get to
maybe like
five million years ago you have the
first bipedal primate so when we started
to
walk then the hands became free and so
then
manipulation the ability to manipulate
objects and build tools and
so on and so forth you said 500 000
years ago no
sorry the the first multi-cellular
animals which you can say
had some intelligence arose 500 million
years million
okay and now let's fast forward to say
the last seven million years
which is the development of the hominid
line right where
from the other primates we have the
branch which leads on to modern humans
now there are many of these uh hominids
but the the the ones which
you know people talk about lucy because
that's like a skeleton from three
million years ago and we know that lucy
walked okay so at this stage you have
that the hand is free for manipulating
objects
and then the ability to manipulate
objects build tools
and the brain size grew
in this era so okay so now you have
manipulation
now we don't know exactly when language
arrows
but after that but after that because no
apes have i mean so i mean chomsky is
correct in that that it is a uniquely
human capability
and uh we primates
other primaries don't have that but so
it developed somewhere in this era
but it developed i would i mean uh
argue that it probably developed after
we had this stage of
humans or i mean the human species
already able to manipulate
and enhance free much bigger brain size
and for that there's a lot of vision
has already had had to have developed
yeah so
the sensation and the perception may be
some of the cognition
yeah so we we so those
so so that so the world so there
so so these ancestors of us
you know three four million years ago
they had
uh they had spatial intelligence so they
knew that the world consists of objects
they knew that the objects were in
certain relationships to each other
they had observed causal
interactions among objects they could
move in space so they had space and time
and all of that
so language builds on that substrate so
language has
a lot of i mean i mean the
all human languages have constructs
which depend on a notion of space and
time
where did that notion of space and time
come from
it had to come from perception and
action in the world we live in
you